قالت اطرافها في الازمه السودانيه انها
توصلت الى تفاهمات لانهاء الازمه السياسيه
التي تتخبط فيها البلاد وقالت قوى الحريه
والتغيير جناح المجلس المركزي لا تعمل على
التواصل الى اتفاق الاطاري مع الجيش قائله
انه وافق على ابقاء مجلس الوزراء مدنيا
بالكامل مشدده على انها لن توقعت فقره
نهائيا دون موافقه جميع القوى الثوريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ابرز نتائج
ومراحل الاتفاق الايطالي وهل سيفضى الى
اتفاق النهائي وتشكيل حكومه مدنيه بالكامل
اي تحديات لقد تواجه الاتفاق في ضوء تاكيد
قيادات في الحريه والتغيير على عدم
التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي دون موافقه
جميع القوى الثوريه
المشهد السياسي بعد هذا الاتفاق وكيف
سنعكس على السودانيين بعدما شهدته البلاد
من ازمه سياسيه واقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
اتفاق ينتظره السودان ليخرج من ازمته في
افقي 10 ايام ذاك على نفسه قوي الحريه
والتغيير جناح المجلس المركزي مشيرتان الى
ان اليهود تنصب حاليا على تواصل الى اتفاق
الايطاليه مع الجيش على ان يتم في المرحله
الثانيه من المحادثات تناول العداله
الانتقاليه وقضايا اخرى خريطه طريق يدرك
المعنيون بها انها تتخذوا من اخراج
السودان من ازمته هدفا تحتاج لتوافق اوسع
حولها يشمل بقيه القوى الثوريه هدف يتطلب
تحقيقه الاقناع بان الهدف من الاتفاق انما
هو تشكيله حكومه مدنيه توقف تدخل الجيش في
الحياه السياسيه وهو عموم يحتاج تفاصيل
سيتضمنها اتفاق تفصيلي يفترض ان يوقع بعد
نحو شهر نتابع بعض ملامح الاتفاق التي كشف
عنها القيادي في قوى الحريه وتغيير الواثق
البرير
هذا التصور يغسل العمليه لمرحلتين على
النحو التالي واحد مرحله الاتفاق الايطالي
الذي يبنى على التفاهمات التي جرت بين قوى
الحريه والتغيير والمكونه العسكري واطراف
قوى الانتقال الديمغرافيه والتي شملت
ملاحظات الجانب العسكري حول الدستور
الانتقالي الذي انتجته ورشه اللجنه
التسيريه لنغابه المحامين ثانيا مرحله
الاتفاق النهائي ويتم فيها تطوير الاتفاق
الايطالي بمشاركه جماهيريه واسعه من اصحاب
المصلحه وقوه الثوره
القيادي في الحريه والتغيير ياسر عرمان
قال ان قوى الحريه والتغيير لن توقع اتفاق
النهائيه مع العسكريين دون موافقه جميع
القوى الثوريه واضاف عمان انه يجب تحقيق
التطلعاته كل السودانيين حسب تعبيرهم
نحن في الحريه
نريد نناقش مناقشه جديه لانه واقع اتفاق
نهائي الا بانناغي الشعبنا وهو الثوره
الاربعه ملفات واختلنا هذه الصيغه بالذات
لحير صنع على المشاركه ومشاركه اصحاب
المصلحه واللي علمنا ان الحريه والتغيير
لن تستطيع ان تحسم دون غيرها من الثوره
اشارات وان صدرت عن قيادات عسكريه في نفس
الاتجاه وان بالعناوين العريضه فلقد اعلن
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني محمد
حمدان حميتي عقب لقائه في الخرطوم مفوض
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان ترك عن توفر
الرغبه والاراده لتجاوز الاوضاع الراهنه
التي يمر بها السودان وتوصل الى اتفاق
يؤدي لاستكمال الفتره الانتقاليه وصولا
الى مرحله الانتخابات
تطورات وانت ردد صداقه فقد قال مفاوض
الامم المتحده سامي لحقوق الانسان للجزيره
ان لديه تفاؤلا حذرا بشان امكانيه التوصل
الى توافق سياسي بين القوى المدنيه
والسلطه العسكريه في السودان واوضحته كان
دور المجتمع الدولي هو دعم اي اطار سياسي
يتوافقوا عليه السوداني
والحكومه الفعليه الحاليه ان يبذولا جهودا
كبيره للتوصل الى توافق سياسي طبعا
المجتمع الدولي موجود لدعم هذه الجهود
ونحن من جانبنا في المفوضيه الساميه نعمل
كل ما بوسعنا لدعم الشعب السوداني في
الحصول على حقوقه لذلك مكتبه
قضايا حقوق الانسان وتقديم التقارير
بشانها لمن بايديهم احداث تغيير مع تاكد
من ان مستقبل السودان يستند الى احترام
حقوق الانسان الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم كلهم
من الدكتور محمد المهدي حسن القيادي في
قوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي ولواء
معتصم عبد القادر الحسن الباحث في
الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه وكمال كرار القيادي بالحزب
الشيوعي السوداني وتحالف التغيير الجذري
مرحبا بكم جميعا دكتور محمد المهدي حسن
الاولى منها خلال 10 ايام اتفاق ايطالي
تنتقل بعد الاتفاق الايطالي في غضون شهر
كما هو مجدول الى مرحله الاتفاق النهائي
ما هو ما هو المتغير الذي سيجعل من هذا
الاتفاق ان كان الاطار والاخر النهائي همم
اتفاقا حقيقيا كما يرد له
وشكرا جزيلا لك ولي
مشاهديك الكرام لضيفيك
ال ال الفكره في ان الاتفاق الايطالي هو
عباره عن عن اعلان مبادئ لقضايا واتفق
عليها وهي قضايا الاساسيه وتبقت ااا بعض
القضايا وهي ايضا لا تغل اهميه عن تلك
التي تم الاتفاق عليها وهذه
الخطوه الاولى همم يعني تعني ان القوه
المنقلب عليها والقوه المنقلبهم من اتفقوا
على القضايا الاساسيه ولكن يجب ان يفتح
الاتفاق ليشمل كل الثوره وكل قوه الانتقال
لانه كما هو معلوم ان انا همم مرحله الى
مرحلتين كما جاء في تقريركم الذي
كان مختطفا من حديث
من حديث الحبيب الوافيه الامين العام لحزب
الامه
المرحله الاولى بهذا الشكل ولكن عندما
نذهب الى المرحله الثانيه وهي التي يجب ان
تستصحب طيفا واسعا من قوه الثوره والقوه
الانتقال التي تؤمن بالتحول الديمقراطي
وتؤمن
بالحل السياسي كذلك
والتي
قبلت وتقبل ال ال
الدستور الانتقالي الذي همم بني او اختطته
لجنه تسييريه اللجنه التسيريه
واستصحى باراء كل القوه المؤمنه بالتحول
الديمقراطي لذلك نحن عندما نذهب الى
المرحله الثانيه بالتاكيد
والثوره
الشامل همم
معتصم همم عند الحديث عن القضايا التي
تضمنها مثل هذا الحديث او خارطه الطريق
للاتفاق الاطار ومن ثم الاتفاق النهائي
جرى الحديث بان هناك قضايا عالقه وهذه
القضايا كما قال الدكتور همم حسن هي لا
تقل اهميه عن القضايا التي جرى تضمنها همم
هل هناك فكره عن هذه القضايا العالقه
وامكانيه ااه وضح حلول الحقيقيه لها
لك التحيه والشكر والتحيه الاضافيك
الكريمين والتحيه للساده المشاهدين ااه لا
اعتقد ان هنالك اي شكل من اشكال الاتفاق
ما اعلن عنه السيد الرئيس البرهان ان هناك
تفاهمات تمت مع هذه القوه
واي اتفاق لا اعتقد انه سيكون ثنائيا
الاتفاق سيكون مفتوحا منذ البدايه هنالك
الان حديث ان هنالك اتفاق اطاري سوف يوقع
ما بين القوه همم المنقلبه والقوه المنقلب
عليها لا يوجد مثل هذا الحديث اذا كانت
هنالك رعايه
وعبر اللجنه الثلاثيه ستفتح الباب للجميع
القوه للمشاركه فيها انا اعتقد ان ما تم
بالامس في المؤتمر الصحفي
او ثنائي عفوا لماذا همم
احد احد الاسباب اللي قرارات او اجراءات
25 اكتوبر ان هنالك احتكار من بعض القوه
للقرار السياسي وللممارسه السياسيه في
السودان هو احد الاهداف اللي تلك القرارات
كانت توسعه المشاركه
وتوسيع المجال لمشاركه القوه اخرى
مواقف محدده لقوه محدده والادعاء بان
هنالك قوى ثوريه حيه ستضاف الى هذه
الاتفاقيه الان لا توجد اي قوه خارج اطار
التمور في في
مبادرات او في وثائق معينه الان هنالك
اربع قوى رئيسيه في الساحه السياسيه
السودانيه كما تعلمين هنالك المجلس
المركزي وهنالك الكتله الديمقراطيه التي
تضم قوه توافق الوطني بالاضافه الى الحسبه
الاتحاد اا الاتحاد الاصلي وحزام اخرى
هنالك التغيير الجذري بقياده الحزب
الشيوعي ههه اجانا المقاومه والبعض
المهنيين وهنالك الكتله اا كتله
الاسلاميين والوطنين الذين
هو كيف يمكن تضمين وفتح هذا الاتفاق ليشمل
الجميع ولكن لم تحدثني عن القضايا العالقه
ولكن وهنا اريد ان ادخل حديثك عنها
حديث عن العداله الانتقاليه هنالك وهذه
ليس هنالك اشكاليه بالنسبه للمكون العسكري
فيها هذه
موجوده نعم وهنالك حديث عن مراجعه اتفاقيه
وهذا له اطراف اخرى اين الاطراف التي وقعت
اه قولنا خبطه الطريق همم لواء معتصم ادهم
انت عزيز تحالف التغيير الجذري اسمح لي
اريد ان اشاركه في هذا المحور ايضا استمع
منه انتم رافضون همم ما جرى الحديث عنه
لهذا همم التوافق على مرحله انتقاليه اطار
انتقالي ومن ثم همم اتفاق نهائي ما الذي
يجعلكم ترفضون مثل هذا همم الاتفاق لماذا
لا يجري فتح الباب للحوار من اجل حل
الازمه والوصول الى حكم سياسي
مساء الخير عليك وعلى المشاهدين وعلى
الذكرى الاولى عليه سقوط شهداء مدينه بحري
في 17
في الفضاء السوداني نقول التسويه قديمه
بصريح العبارات
هي محاوله الانتاج نفس الشراكه ونفس
اللازمه السياسيه التي يعاني منها السودان
56 وهي تريد تقنين هذا وجود هذا الانقلاب
العسكري
الذي حدث في 25 اكتوبر من العام الماضي
وهي تريد ان يعني تقطع الطريق على الثوره
لوجهه نظرنا فيما يتعلق بهذه يعني
المثاورات وال نحن بنسميها يعني المؤامرات
لقطع الطريق على الثوره ولكن يعني رؤيتنا
في التغيير ورؤيه اخرون معنا في الايام
المقاومه وهكذا يعني انه هذا الانقلاب
يضبط بالعمل الجماهيري السوري موجود في
الشارع اللي هو لا تفاوض لا شاركه ولاء
مساومه وهذا النوع من التفاهم يعني الاطار
وكده يعني اللي بتقوله الحريه والتغيير
يعني المجلس المركزي اول توفى وطنه او
خلافه يعني يهدم هذا يعني همم
الثلاثه اللي هي لا تفاوض يعني وما بنفتكر
انه في انقلاب حصل في السودان قبل كده
يعني شنو يعني بالحوار بالتفاهمات وبعد
كده هو ينزح عن طريق الشعب السوداني عن
طريق الجدري او تحقيق اهداف واستكمال
اهداف ترتيب هذا العمل السياسه
ذلك يعني باب مفتوح للبديله الديمقراطي
والوطني الذي يستكمل مهام واهداف ثوره
ديسمبر ومعظم التدريب والتنوين بها التطور
الوطني الديمقراطي السوداني يعني هناك
جمله سيد حسن سيد همم المهدي حسن الصقلي
النقطه همم المهمه ربما التحديات الكبيره
يبدو بان هناك ليست يعني فقط قضايا عالقه
ضمن هذه التفاهمات في الاطار وان هناك
قضايا كبيره على طرفي همم هذا الاتفاق ان
كان من قوى ثوريه الرافضه له المتحفظه
عليه وان كان ايضا ربما ضمن همم يعني
المجلس او المكون العسكري وما يراه كيف
السبيل الى
الوصول الى تفاهمات حقيقيه همم تذهب الى
تحقيق هذا الاتفاق
هو نحن طبعا لا نقول ان هنالك التسويه كما
يتفضل الاخ كمال نحن نتكلم عن نتحدث عن
اتفاق اتفاق يعني شامل لكل القضايا لكل
الاطراف المؤمنه لتحول الديمقراطي
كلمه التسويه هذه اطلقتها قوه معاديه
للاتفاق اصلا
ولكنها لم ترد اصلا في ادبياتنا ولا حتى
في احاديث وتصريحات المكونه العسكري الذي
نتحاور معه
النقطه الثانيه اننا لا نتحدث عن لقاء
ثنائي كذلك اتفاق ثنائي بيننا وبين
العسكري وانما نتحدث عن اتفاق شامل لكل
ال- اا القوه السياسيه لكل القضايا يعني
حسن
ايوه ايوه النقطه الثالثه هنالك ان ما حدث
في 25 اكتوبر انقلاب اصلا ترى ان ذلك يعني
امرا تصحيحيا وبالتالي هي من دعمت وحرضت
وظهرت واعتصبت امام القصر وتطالب المكون
العسكري بان يعني يعلن البيان وتتحدث انها
لم ترجع الى البيوت الا بعد البيان يطلع
وهذه القوه بالتالي هي مرحلتها اخرى لانها
لا ترى ان هذا انقلاب عندما ناتي الى
القضايا الكليه همم ضروري جدا ان تكون
جزءا من من ال- ال- الحوار الشامل باعتبار
انها قوات سودانيه موجوده اخطات اخطات
التقدير ودخلت البلاد بتحريضها وقبولها
العسكري بان ينقلب على تحول الديمقراطي
الرابعه
ضمن هذا النتيجه اتجاهكم هو تجميع جميع
القوى الثوريه على
الموافقه على هذا الاتفاق خاصه بان المجلس
المركزي تحدث انه لا ذهب لاتفاق اذا لم
توافق جميع القوى الثوريه عليه
القوه الثوريه هنالك تواصل معها بالمناسبه
هنالك تواصل معها مع كل الخلافات التي
ضربت الساحه السياسيه في الفتره الماضيه
ولكن هنالك تواصل معها واعتقد انها ستمضي
في اتجاه القبور الاتفاق لانه ليس هنالك
خيار اخر غير ان يتحاور الناس
للوصول الى حل ينهي الازمه ويمكن الفتره
الانتقاليه من ان تستانف مسيرتها نحو
الانتخابات ولذلك التمتروس حول القضايا
والتمتروس حول المواقف همم حقيقه لا
يؤدي الا الى مزيد من التعقيد
للازمه السياسيه التي تعددت واستعصت على
الحل لذلك تجددوننا وتجدوننا نحن
نصل ليلنا بنها بحث عن دون التفريط في
الثوابت واضحه ثوابت السرعه
الثقه عامل كبير اليوم في الشارع كان هناك
تظاهرات
واغلاقات
ومواجهه هذه التظاهرات
وكيف يمكن همم يعني ردم هذه الهوى والوصول
الى مرحله ثقه لا زالت حتى الان مفقوده
واضح انها مفقوده
المدنيه دور كبير ان تتحدث لي عن التحديات
اريد ان ادمج هذا اجاوب على سؤالك عبر
الحديث عن التحديات هنالك تحدي كبير ان
هنالك قوى تدعي الوصايه على القوه المدنيه
الاخرى وتصادر حقها في التشارك وفي
التفاوض وهمم تدعي انها هي التي تتفاوض مع
همم الذين يستلمون ذماما الامور الان
اعتقد هذا تحدي كبير جدا
ايضا من قبل الشارع والمكون الثوري مع
المكون العسكري
انا اعتقد ان مطالب الشارع بحل القضيه
المدنيه او قضيه الحكم في السودان كثير من
مطالب الشارع يجب الاستجابه لو هذا التحدي
الثاني الذي يكون ساتحدث عنه ان هناك
مشاكل حقيقيه معيشيه وامنيه ومشاكل
التنميه الان تحدث في السودان
فهذه هذا اكبر تحديانات عن القوه المدنيه
ان تكون واعيه تماما وان تتقبل المشاركه
بقيه القوه معها وان لا تحاول احتكار
الوطن لا يوجد مواطن افضل او قوه سياسيه
افضل من الاخرى انا اعتقد
الخروج من هذه القوقعه ومشار- والقبول
بمشاركه اخرين في الحياه السياسيه
السودانيه انا اعتقد انه هو الحل
ما نواجهه الان من اشكالات في الحياه
السياسيه السودانيه
في المرحله المقبله الى اي درجه همم
شارع السوداني بحاجه الى قراءه ربما توصف
بالواقعيه اكثر من الحالات العدم
او ربما حاله وسطيه يمكن الذهاب من خلال
مثل هذا الاتفاق من اجل الوصول الى مبتغى
الشارع بنهايه الشعارات يجب ان لا تكون
مفتوحه يجب ان تصل الى مسار حكم سياسي
ولا نختار الخيارات العالميه يعني نرى ان
الطريقه الوحيد المؤدي الى يعني انتصار
الثوره والى السودان الوطني الديمقراطي
يمر عبر الثورها عبر انتصار هذه الثوره
وهذا الكلام يعني عن همم عن الحوارات او
التسويات او خلافه يعني قيل ايضا في ما
قبل سقوط مخلوع البشير يعني قيل في
2018/2017 وكان خيارنا الثوره وكان خيار
اخرون الحوارات والتفاهمات وخاطه الطريق
وكده ولكن انتصر خيار الثوره الكلام ده في
التاريخ يعني من قبل اربع سنوات وليس يعني
وليس في التاريخ البعيد نحن نؤمن امامنا
قاطعا وقلت هذه الجماهير على اسقاط هذا
الانقلاب وبناء الدوله يعني المدنيه
المنشوده يعني والاقتصاد للشهداء وكده
يعني لا يوجد طريق نراه نحن في الهند
الشيوخ غير هذا الطريقه حتى الان نعيد
انتاج يعني السودان المتخلفه سودانيات
والسودان الحكم العسكري وكده ده يعني
انه الحديث حول الاتفاقات الايطاليه او
خلافها او يعني ما سمعته من الضيفين يعني
سواء كان في معرض الحديث عن الوثيقه بتاعه
المحامين اللي هي الاعلان الدستوري بتاع
اللجنه التسيري للمحاميين او سو وكان
الحديث اللي قالوا زميلنا هسه مع التظلم
حول حول الانفرات بعض
يعني اديته من
السياسيين بالفرد العمليه السياسيه وكده
يعني يعني وكاننا يعني مجلس المركز يعني
اقصى الاخرين او كده يعني في الاطار ده شو
في هذا نوع من الخلافات
على المناصب والمحافظات وعلى شكل السلطه
الانتقاليه اللي هي يعني المناظر وكده
يعني والناس لا تنظر الى طريقه حكم
السودان ولا طريقه يعني همم سقوط هذا
الانقلاب هذه الانقلاب يضغط عن طريق يعني
العمل
الجماهير يعني موجود الان في الشارع
واليوم كلنا هذه الصوره المستعمله في
الشارع
خلال اشهر الماضيه الحين اسقط الانقلاب
هذا هو الاخير يعني
الجدري كما الكرار واشكر ايضا الموصول
للواء معتصم عبد القادر الحسن الباحث في
الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه والدكتور ايضا محمد المهدي
حسن القيادي في قوى الحريه والتغيير مجلس
المركزي شكرا لكم جميعا
لهنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]